mientras miles de soldados rusos están
desplegados en la frontera con ucrania
la unión europea que quiere evitar
cualquier incursión amenazada moscú con
nuevas sanciones de mestrets ver y creer
el mensaje es muy claro si rusia
emprende nuevas acciones agresivas
contra ucrania los costes serán elevados
y las consecuencias graves falsas serios
por su parte el presidente ucraniano
quien se reunió con funcionarios del
bloque en bruselas dijo que los europeos
deben actuar con mayor celeridad aplicar
sanciones después de un posible ataque
de rusia sería demasiado tarde nosotros
estamos interesados en una poderosa
política de sanciones ante una posible
escalada y esto creo podría prevenir un
ataque la unión europea está dividida
sobre qué tipo de sanciones podría
imponer a rusia sus medidas anteriores
no impidieron que los rusos anexarán la
península de crimea y permanecieran en
los territorios que ocupan en ucrania
mientras tanto vladimir putin no ha
reaccionado a las amenazas de los
europeos y se ha dirigido directamente a
washington su objetivo es evitar que la
otan despliegue tropas más cerca de
rusia al mismo tiempo la organización
y desaprueba el comportamiento militar
ruso alertando que la presencia militar
no disminuye por ahora moscú comunicó a
la administración estadounidense sus
condiciones de seguridad para retroceder
desde la frontera